>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Gail Shirazi: This
program is being sponsored
by the European Division
at the Library of Congress,
and the Hebrew Language Table
at the Library of Congress.
I would like to thank at LC
Grant Harris [assumed spelling],
Erica Spenser [assumed spelling],
Audrey Fisher [assumed spelling],
and Galina Teberoski [phonetic].
Today we'll hear two very different
approaches to Holocaust stories.
Our Crime Was Being Jewish contains
memoirs of 358 Holocaust survivors,
and Auschwitz #34207 tells the
story of one, Joe Rubinstein.
Our panel will be moderated
by Michlean Lowry Amir whose
is Reference Coordinator
of the Holocaust Survivors
and Victim Center
at the United States
Holocaust Memorial Museum.
And as part of her job she's
always helping researchers,
and she's always throwing
these speakers.
And she says, Gail, you've
got to have this speaker.
So that's how our two wonderful
speakers came to us today.
Michlean is going to be
moderating, questions
and answers will follow
at the very end.
Thank you.
Michlean?
[ Applause ]
>> Michlean Amir: Well,
thank you all for coming.
For me it's an honor and a privilege
to be here and moderate two authors
who I are I think very,
very special.
And I'm sure you will feel the same
at the end of this presentation.
I thank Gail for inviting me to
be part of this event which is
in a way a commemoration
of Kristallnacht
which happened November
9th and 10, 1938.
I just want to say a
few words about that.
Kristallnacht is not a word that
Holocaust survivors like to use
for this event because it has
a little positive connotation.
You know, Kristall is beautiful.
So they prefer to call it
the night of broken glass.
The I guess excuse for that
evening, for that night,
was the fact that a young man by
the name of Herschel Grynszpan,
who was 17 years old, was very,
very frustrated because in 1938,
towards the end of 1938, many
German Jewish people who were
of Polish descent were
suddenly sent back to Poland.
Some of these people were in
Germany from 1900 and even before.
Herschel Grynszpan's
parents were there from 1911.
And he was so upset that they were
sent to Zbaszyn which was a town
on the border of Poland and Germany.
So they were in a camp in
Poland and had nowhere to go.
They had lost all their
contacts in Poland,
and so were many other people.
So he went to the German
Embassy in Paris,
and was very frustrated
talking to Ernst vom Rath
who was an employee
at the embassy there.
And finally he just took
out his gun and shot him.
And that was the excuse for
everything that happened that night.
It was encouraged by two well
known Nazis, Hydriff [phonetic]
and Gerbals [phonetic], and that
evening 267 synagogues in Germany,
Austria and in the
Protectorate were burned
down as were 7,500 Jewish
businesses, many Jewish cemeteries,
Jewish schools and Jewish homes.
So it was really the beginning of
what we now call the Holocaust.
And I think this presentation
is very, very appropriate
to remember that horrendous day.
So I have to admit that I'm not
an objective presenter here.
I have known the authors, Tony,
for a very, very long time
and his works, his
books for a long time.
I know he's an excellent
author and so is this book.
I like to always remember the moment
when I saw President Clinton going
on vacation to Martha's Vineyard
with Tony's book on the Burning
of Washington in his hand
so the world could see it.
And that was fantastic publicity.
And, of course, his book
on the assassination
of President Lincoln
is also very famous
as are his other 10 or 11 books.
And so the years that I've
known him I won't even tell you
because it's so many.
I haven't known Nancy as many
years, but I feel very close to her
because we've worked both
with Tony and with Nancy
on their research actually
from the very beginning
when they just started thinking
about writing their books.
I think Tony was not sure exactly
what he wanted to do immediately,
and I'm sure you'll hear
that a little later.
But he knew that it was time for him
to write a book on the Holocaust.
And Nancy was fortunate I think, as
was Joe Rubinstein that they met,
and eventually the book has been
written, and it is here available
and of information to
everyone around the world.
And I know Nancy is in
contact with people all
over the world because of the book.
So our work together was at the
Holocaust Museum where I have been
for 16 years in working in
reference, now more specifically
on the fate of individuals.
And, therefore, Joe
Rubinstein's store was exactly
in my area of research.
And we did find all kinds of
information on him during the war,
how he moved from camp
to camp, and how he came
to the United States and so forth.
And when Tony eventually
decided that he wanted to look
into oral histories, we worked
together to see which ones
and how he would access them.
The museum has an enormous
resource for Holocaust studies.
Not only does the museum
have its own Center
for Advanced Holocaust Studies
where there are scholars,
but there are also interns and
fellows a the museum all the time
from all around the world.
And they work on so
many different areas.
We know that the Holocaust
is the most documented event
in human history.
So the documentation is enormous.
We have in the library
over 100,000 books.
These books are in every
language that you can imagine.
Any book that's been
written on any aspect
of the Holocaust the
museum tries to get.
And so there are books in Chinese
and in Japanese and languages
that you would not imagine.
And there are 100 million
pages of archival information.
The museum has been collecting
this for over 21 years.
That's how long the
museum has been open.
But many years before that when it
was just an idea information started
to be collected.
So that, and then there
are 100,000 photographs
and 10,000 or more interviews.
So for all these scholars when they
come to research they need help
to navigate through this
wealth of information.
And that's what we do when we help
them in doing the reference work.
A lot of the information is
available on the website.
But, of course, much has
not been digitized yet.
It is I think the idea that
eventually this will happen,
but it will be a long time
because those of you who have been
to the museum to the permanent
exhibit, everything that's there is
about five percent of
what the museum has.
The rest, the 95 percent is
kept in a state of the art area
where temperature, pressure
and humidity are very,
very carefully controlled.
And we are building a new
structure just for that.
So my interaction with these two
authors has been very interesting.
And to see how the process evolved
so that there is a book
is always amazing to me.
Because sometimes it's an idea in
someone's mind, and it takes five
or sometimes even ten
years to see the product
and be able to actually read it.
I think that both Nancy and Tony
had in mind the words of Elie Wiesel
who warned that only those who were
there can write about the Holocaust.
And that's why I think they went
to the horse's mouth, so to speak,
to those survivors
who were interviewed
or the survivor was alive.
And I think they're
also trying to make sure
that these memories are
there for us to remember.
Because Elie Wiesel also said
that if we forget we'll cause
them to have a second death.
And unfortunately that is true.
The only thing that we
have really from those
who were there are the memoirs and
oral histories of those who survive.
So they used raw testimonies,
and for Our Crime Was
Being Jewish Tony combed
through the museum's oral history
interviews and listened to,
as you heard, 358 of them
and pulled out of them some
of the most powerful and
poignant testimonies.
Symbolically that book is like
the chaos of the Holocaust.
There's no arrangement.
It's not arranged by geographical
place or in any other way,
not chronologically or by subject.
And there's no index because
I think the author felt
that if he indexed the
358 names one would think
that these were all of them.
But all the others,
especially the victims,
would not have been on the list.
And those evil acts that were
perpetrated by the Nazis are
so coldly described in the
passages that Tony pulled
out that one is left holding
your breath in disbelief.
I think this book will be a very
useful resource for teachers
of all age because the
information is right there.
And they will not have to comb
through all these interviews
as Tony had to.
And it is really excellent
documentation of those crimes.
Nancy Geise, on the other
hand, focused on one person.
And she interviewed him masterfully.
He was very reluctant at first.
Actually, you will hear from
Nancy, did not want to talk.
I think it just was too
painful for him to remember.
But after several years
possibly because of his guilt
that he was the only one that
survived he felt that he needed
to talk to be the one who would
record what happened to his family,
too, everyone in his family.
His fortune was that he was a
very positive thinking person.
Because even in the total
darkness of the war he was able
to see some rays of light.
And he was able to make a new and
wonderful life in the United States
for himself and his family.
And you will hear more
about it very soon.
Nancy's book is very readable.
She divided it into sections,
and they are very accessible.
She provides historical
background to events describe
by Auschwitz prisoner #34201.
And she included maps, documents,
photographs and a time line
so that one could read it and
really get the background,
not just what happened to Joe
but what was happening
during the war at that time.
The reviews of both books
have been excellent,
and you might hear more about that.
And I think we're really very
fortunate to have Anthony Pitch
and Nancy Geise talk about the
issues of writing the Holocaust.
So I invite Tony to come up here,
and I have some questions for you
so that we will hear how this
process of writing went on.
My first question is what led
you to decide after all the books
that you wrote that you needed to
write a book about the Holocaust?
>> Anthony Pitch: Good question.
Look, I must at the
beginning apologize.
I had a stroke, and my short-term
memory is not what it used to be.
In fact, I recently forgot
what I was talking about.
I hope it doesn't happen today.
Why did I choose the Holocaust?
I had always been attracted
by subjects
that were epic, true and sad.
I don't know why, but
that's a fact of life.
And that's why I wrote about
Vietnam, [inaudible] held prisoner,
the burning of the White House
and the capital by the British,
the Lincoln assassination.
They all fit that mold.
And then I thought, well, the
Holocaust is in that mold also.
And probably it was my daughter
said to me don't touch it.
It's been overdone, it's
been written by everybody.
There's nothing new you can say.
And I accepted that,
and I put it aside.
And then one day I was
looking at at YouTube,
and I saw Dieudonne M'bala M'bala.
He is a Frenchman whose
father was Cameroonian
and his mother was French.
He lives in France.
And this is the ranking anti-semite
in Europe today, Dieudonne
M'Bala M'Bala.
He has an enormous following
and he ridicules the Holocaust.
He has Shoananas, shoa you know
and ananas is pineapple in French.
And he plays with the pineapple
while he's ridiculing the Holocaust.
And he's making a fortune,
and he's getting followers
like nobody's business.
It so infuriated me that
I had to reply to him.
And the best method I could do was
by getting the Holocaust
survivors themselves
to tell him what they went
through, what they endured.
And that's why I chose this book.
And I wrote the preface, that's all.
I let them speak for themselves.
I excerpted brief amounts that
they could describe the range
of atrocities.
And it's one of those things that
all Holocaust survivors have,
the urge to record it for
a world naive to believe
that it appears again and again.
And these are their
statements, not mine.
It's their wisdom.
>> Michlean Amir: So
my next question is,
although you partially answered it,
but how was writing this book
different from writing about Lincoln
or about the White House?
Writing it how was that different?
>> Anthony Pitch: It's
different in this respect.
I had to insert myself
into my other books.
And I did research from
Harvard right down to Alabama.
Any document I could get hold of.
There are state historical
societies all over the place.
There's no end to the research.
This one was quite easy for me
because I let the people
speak for themselves.
My only insertion of
myself was to edit
because English was not the mother
tongue of many of these people.
In fact, I probably
went through much more
than 1,000 of these interviews.
And some of them the English was not
quite good enough even for editing.
And so I chose those who would
show the range of atrocities.
And it was rather like
being at an operation.
I can stand blood, the slight
of it, I can watch these things
on TV, it doesn't matter.
Many people have said to
me how did you manage it?
It's so frightening.
But you can't write about the
Holocaust unless you describe how
it was.
>> Michlean Amir: So that leads
me to the next question which,
again, you partially answered.
Was it emotionally difficult for you
to deal with these interviews day in
and day out, during the night when
you were reading them so thoroughly?
Did it leave an effect on you the
next day or for a long period?
>> Strangely it didn't.
It should have but it didn't.
I don't know why.
It was like when I visited Auschwitz
it was all scrubbed and clean.
You couldn't smell it.
You couldn't see the people
suffering, skeletons walking around.
It was all scrubbed and clean.
And that's the effect
that this had on me.
Many people express surprise.
They said how did you
get through it?
And I don't know, but
that's an individual thing.
It really didn't affect me, but know
that if you read this book
you probably may not be able
to finish it.
It's so horrific, and this is really
my reply to Dieudonne M'bala M'bala.
They spoke and they answered him.
>> I think that Michael Barenbaum
gave you a wonderful forward
for the book, and you
were fortunate to him.
And we were fortunate because
he added to your forward.
So one more question I have.
And that is did you have any
difficulties getting a publisher?
I constantly hear it from
writers about the Holocaust
that it's impossible
to get a publisher.
Can you tell us about the
process of getting a publisher?
>> Anthony Pitch: I wish
I could answer that.
They are a curse.
[Laughter] I don't know the secret
to it, but I have no problem in this
because my agent was Jewish,
and he took it like that,
and he placed it very quickly.
It was all done in
a couple of weeks.
J.K. Rowling had multiple, multiple
rejections before Harry Potter
was accepted.
So it's really one person's opinion.
Jonathan Livingston
Seagull the same thing.
And you could name
all these bestsellers.
It's really one lousy person
in the publishing business.
[Laughter]
>> Michlean Amir: So here
we're quite limited on time.
I just wanted to see
if there was anything
that you wanted to
add to the questions.
Any answer, any description
you're welcome to do it.
And then we'll invite
Nancy to come up.
>> Anthony Pitch: I
really don't have any,
I'd rather respond to questions.
But what you have coming
up now is marvelous.
Nancy is a wonderful speaker.
>> Michlean Amir: Thank you.
[Applause] Thank you,
Tony, very much.
Nancy, we're anxiously
waiting to hear
about the story of Joe Rubinstein.
And if you could respond
to these questions as well
as you talk that would be great.
>> Nancy Geise: Perfect.
Well, thank you so much.
I just first have to say thank
you, Gail, thank you Michlean.
I'm so honored to be
here with Anthony Pitch.
His book is marvelous.
And, Anthony, I just
want to say thank you
on behalf of future generations.
What you've done is a tremendous
gift so thank you very much.
I'm so honored to be here.
I came in from Topeka,
Kansas to be here.
I think half the state of
Kansas knows that I'm here.
And the other part I'm
making sure they do know.
But I want to say thank you
for the opportunity to be
at the Library of Congress.
It truly is one of the
greatest honors of my life.
To share with you a little bit
about a truly remarkable man
who survived -- can you hear me
okay, who survived really everything
that the Nazis tried to do
the Jews with the exception
of killing him which
they nearly did.
So I'll try to answer some of the
questions and give you a little bit
of background on Joe
and how I met him.
Because Joe was raised in a
town called Radom, Poland.
He was born in 1920.
And when he was five years
old his father passed away,
and life got very, very difficult
at that point for his family.
His mother was widowed
raising five children.
And all the kids were
just incredible kids.
They all did everything they could
to help keep food on the table.
When Joe was 12 years old he would
go from school to then working
in a lumberyard to then after that
learning to make shoes at night.
So they were just really
hardworking, loving, loving family.
And when the Nazis
invaded, of course,
they moved all the Jewish people.
There were about, I've
heard estimates anywhere
from 30,000 people moved into the
two ghetto areas of Radom, and Joe
and his family were among them.
I first met Joe in 2007.
It was rather unusual.
And I'm a very unlikely
person to be standing here.
I'm not Jewish.
I'm certainly not a
Holocaust scholar.
If you told me a few years ago
that I would be writing this story
I would have told you're crazy.
That's not possible, certainly
not possible to be here.
But I was working at a
retirement community in Ft.
Collins, Colorado, and
Joe and his wife were two
of our first residents
that moved in.
And one of my co-workers told me
that Joe was a Holocaust survivor.
And so I asked him -- a while
later I saw a little portion
of his tattoo sticking
out from under his arm.
He's got a tattoo that runs
the length of his forearm,
and he keeps it covered always.
But I saw a portion of it
and asked him about it,
and he said it's from Auschwitz.
And I said, Joe, our daughter
is majoring in history.
Would it be okay if she interviewed
you for one of her classes.
And Joe said, never.
I will never talk about it.
I didn't realize then that in
over 70 years he had
never shared his story.
Even his family knew
just bits and pieces.
It was so incredibly
painful for him.
That was in 2007.
And then I moved with my husband
to Topeka, Kansas, but Joe
and I remained really close.
He's just a phenomenal man.
He is the most joy filled
man I've ever known.
And so we remained close.
And I came back for a visit five
years after I first asked Joe
if I could write -- or if my
daughter could interview him.
And I was back for a visit.
I ran into Joe, and literally
out of the blue he said, Nancy,
I'd like to tell you my story.
So I dropped everything.
I went over to his house, and I
had no idea what it was I would be
writing or hearing.
I thought maybe it would be a
little keepsake for his family.
But as soon as he started
talking I knew
that this was a story the world
was going to want to hear.
And it proved to be the case.
I'm hearing from people
all over the world
about the impact Joe's
story is having on them.
People are telling me that if Joe
overcame everything that he did
and did so with joy,
that they can deal
with whatever they're dealing with.
I heard from somebody from New
Zealand a couple weeks ago.
A German police officer contacted
me a couple weeks ago and told me
that because of Joe's story it's
changed his life, and he is vowing
that it never happen again.
And I love that.
So as Joe began to talk
he told me that he wanted
to get it all out once and for all.
A to Z he told me, A to Z I'm
going to tell you everything.
And he began with extraordinary
detail.
Do you all remember the move The
Titanic, the fictional version?
And they asked the very elderly Rose
at the very beginning tell
us anything you can remember.
They don't think she'll
remember everything.
And she says, I can still
smell the fresh paint.
That was the detail that Joe
started telling me his story.
He began like this.
It was four o'clock in the morning
and someone was pounding at my door.
And I knew that someone pounding
at my door at four o'clock
on the morning could only mean
trouble, and I didn't want trouble.
We had had so much trouble
since the Nazis had invaded.
I wanted to go back to bed.
I wanted to pretend none
of it was happening.
But as the oldest male in the
house I knew it was up to me now
to handle what was on the
other side of that door.
So I walked across the floor,
and my hand was trembling
as I reached for it.
And as I opened the door two
German soldiers were standing there
with machine guns in hand
ordering me to come with them.
And I told them but I
haven't done anything wrong.
And they said you come with me.
But I need to say goodbye
to my family.
I need to change my clothes.
They said you have
everything you need.
And I looked down at my bare
feet, my sorts and my t-shirt,
and I thought everything I need?
And then they walked me outside
into the bitterly cold air,
and they put me on an open
air truck with no protection
where I would be huddled
with strangers.
Several would die.
And that's the detail that Joe
started telling me the story.
And I was thinking, oh my
goodness, all I need to write
down his words and,
Joe, here's your story.
And then a really strange
thing happened.
So we went from that
detail, and he said,
and then they took me to Auschwitz.
And while I was there I
worked in a coal mine.
And then after that, after
the war I went to New York.
And I jokingly said
I had A and I had Z
which Joe was said he was
going to tell me A to Z,
but I had nothing in between.
And my next book is surely going
to be called getting
to Z. Because I did.
I spent the next almost
three years trying to figure
out what happened in between.
Because it was so incredibly
painful for Joe to share this.
Seventy years he had tried
not to talk about it.
Until he shared his story with me
he never told anyone what he did
to survive at Auschwitz.
His job was moving the bodies
of the dead from the gas chamber
to the open pits, pushing them
in a wooden handcart all the
while praying for the souls
of those he pushed and praying
that he wouldn't find his
family among those dead.
And until he shared his story
with me he never told anyone,
anyone that while at Auschwitz
he had been repeatedly
sexually assaulted.
Seventy plus years he kept that
hidden and tight and closed.
And that to me is also one of
the miracles of this story.
Joe was so incredibly worried about
his family learning about this.
His grandkids, they're adults
now, but one of them said
to him afterwards, grandpa,
I've never loved you more.
And that was one of the greatest
blessings anyone could give
to their grandfather,
someone who felt
that if anyone knew
they may not love him.
And it's such an important
lesson for all of us.
So Joe was taken to Auschwitz.
He arrived, and I thankfully
know this
because of the Holocaust
Museum, April 30, 1942.
He was at Auschwitz over two
years proper before being taken
to several other camps:
Buchenwald, Ohrdruf and, finally,
right before the end of
the war Theresienstadt.
Just before the end of the war Joe
and as the Soviet Army was
approaching that camp was in chaos.
The Red Cross was coming in.
The Soviets were advancing.
And Joe looked out one day
and he saw the Nazi guards
pulling civilian clothes
over their uniforms.
And Joe said to the man next
to him, what's going on?
And they said it's over.
They're going to hide.
And suddenly there was
about two or three days
that there was just
chaos in the camp.
Eventually it would be
quarantined and shut down.
But for a couple days
the gates were just open,
and Joe said there was a sign
packed up saying you're free to go.
And he was convinced
that if they walked
through that gate he would be shot.
But he said I was so
sick I didn't care.
I was going to die anyway.
And he simply with the help of
two buddies walked out to freedom.
And so while Joe's story is a
tremendous story of heartache,
he never knew when he
was taken from his home
that he would never again see
another member of his family.
He had no idea that he would
never again return to Poland.
He has never been back home.
That's something you
could keep in your prayers
because Joe is struggling
with this decision.
He would really like to
go, but he's also worried
about going as you can imagine.
You could also keep in your prayers
that we could find a
photo of his family.
Joe said he would give anything
for one photo of his family.
He says he can remember the
faces of his brothers as clearly
as if it were yesterday, but
he can no longer remember his
mother's face.
So I just know there's a
photo out there somewhere.
So, please, if you know anyone who
could help us find it let me know.
That would be a tremendous
gift we can give him.
And Joe went on to live an
extraordinary life afterwards.
You'll have to find out more.
We don't have a lot of time.
But just briefly immediately after
the war he didn't know where to go.
He knew he couldn't
go back to Poland.
He didn't have a dime to his name.
He was sick.
He lost everything a human
being can lose but his life.
And his buddy next to him said, you
know, I'm Jewish, I'm from Germany,
I had a business before
the war, I'm going back.
And, Joe, you should come
back with me until you heal
until you know what else to do.
And so of all places Joe
went back to Germany or went
to Germany after the war.
And he's standing on a street
corner one day and a man taps him
on the shoulder and says,
is that a Polish accent?
And Joe said, yes, and the man said,
well, I'm from Poland originally,
although he had lived in
Germany during the war.
And they got to talking,
and he said,
would you like to come
to my home for dinner?
And Joe said, sure.
And the man said and, by the
way, I have a beautiful daughter.
Well, that beautiful daughter
and Joe have now been married
over 65 years, actually 68 years,
and she is a German Catholic,
married this Jewish man.
And that's one of the
brilliant things
about Joe's story he tells everyone
I don't care what religion you are.
I don't care the color of your skin.
We must love one another.
And Joe lives that and
breathes that with every aspect
of his life including
who he married.
And I think that's
one of the things,
the reason this story is
touching so many lives.
It doesn't matter if people are
Jewish or Catholic or Protestant
or even Atheists are telling
me this was having an impact.
And to me that's another
miracle of Joe's story.
So he went on to New York.
He had an extraordinary career.
He became one of the
leading shoe designers
in New York if not the world.
And he is just an incredibly,
joy filled man.
He's 95 now.
He looks like he's
75, acts like he's 75.
He is incredible.
And he just tells me
to tell everyone,
tell everyone, Nancy,
life is precious.
It's the most precious
gift we have from God.
We must love one another.
We must love life.
And we must love God.
And he says that to
tell me to everyone.
And so on behalf of
Joe I'm telling you.
I'll stop there and see if
you have anymore questions.
We're going to have a brief video.
One thing I wanted to --
it's about nine minutes long.
And Joe's story is remarkable in
another sense in that just one thing
after another happened to save his
life, a little bit like Unbroken.
One of those things, and he
talks about it just briefly,
was at one point -- the inmates were
tattooed when they first got there.
Joe said that he was brought back
in later with a group of people.
And they were being tattooed
most of them with the triangle
which was the sign for being Jewish.
And for whatever reason the man
looking at Joe looked at him
and said, you know what,
you don't look Jewish to me,
whatever that means, and said
I'm not giving you that sign.
And he put on instead of
a triangle he put on a V
which meant political prisoner.
And that designation, the
difference between a V
and a triangle was one line of ink.
One stroke of ink saved Joe's life.
They certainly knew Joe was Jewish.
He wasn't a political prisoner.
We have no idea how he
got that designation,
but all his documents say
Jewish political prisoner.
And because of that he credits
that to having saved his
life, one line of ink.
>> Joe Rubinstein: Life
is very precious, very.
I love life and I always did.
So I did not give it up no
matter what condition I was.
Usually the [inaudible] for
the Jewish [inaudible] used
to put the David Star on.
And the guy who did that he
said I'm not crucifying you.
So he put that V on me.
I was blessed, you know [inaudible],
I'm sitting here 93 years old.
I have a beautiful family, beautiful
grandkids, and I worked all my life.
I never was afraid of hard work.
I was just a kid.
Of course I'm scared.
Who wouldn't be scared.
Who wants to die?
Everybody wants to live.
Well, I tell you when they took
me away I did not believe it
that they're going to --
I said they're going to
just ask me questions.
I did not believe that
they're going to take me.
Now, after I opened the door
and I [inaudible] the door forever
never to see my folks again.
I said that cannot
happen, it will not happen.
We didn't do nothing wrong.
Why? That was my question, why?
On the train you couldn't
help each other, you know.
You just did.
You were so jammed in.
It was so hot, we had no air.
So it was hot enough on
the train with the people.
Everyday, everyday lots of bodies.
Thousands of them.
There were big, big
graves, big ones.
And then they [inaudible]
and then the covered them.
You could not survive.
I knew that.
I myself sometimes
was thinking about it.
The people didn't want to suffer.
They know they're going to die.
They didn't want to die
and that [inaudible]
so they took their own lives.
They went to the electric wire.
That was the easiest way to
die, electrocute themself.
[Inaudible], no, I wanted to live.
You call it day-by-day,
living, day-by-day.
You don't know if you're going
to survive another
night or another day.
You figure you're next in line.
When I was in camp
already I was thinking
about it what I'm going
to do when I get out.
I have to do something.
I have the most [inaudible]
shoes in my life.
Wooden clogs.
And I got blisters all over,
and I've got to walk with them.
I said if you want
to kill me, kill me.
I cannot go to work
with those shoes.
And he said to me go in there
and I'll tell them you
give you other shoes.
You happen to be a very nice
kid, you should not suffer.
And I went in, and he gave the
orders to give me other shoes.
There was a general which
was running the camp.
He got the orders to kill
every one of us, all of them.
Then he said, no, I'm
not going to do it.
[Inaudible] then he opened the
camps, everybody is free to go.
All us, anybody.
And he told the soldiers not
to touch us, to leave us go,
the general who was in charge.
That was already [inaudible]
the generals got beaten
for all [inaudible].
We didn't have no chance
of survival anyway.
We went into the stores
[inaudible] get your clothing.
We didn't have [inaudible]
they are naked.
They were so afraid, they said
anything you want to take it.
It's yours to take.
We know what you've been
through [inaudible].
I'm a survivor, you know?
And I said, well, I'm the only
one survivor of all of my family.
And I have to fill out a
form where I'd like to go,
and I choosed the United States.
>> Irene Rubinstein: When we
arrived, when we got off the ship,
I went down and I kissed the ground.
And I said, thank God
I'm in the United States.
And I was so happy.
>> Joe Rubinstein: I wanted
to be a fashion designer.
I met some people, and I
told them if I design shoes,
I'm a sketch designer in shoes.
And the guy said, you
know what, I have somebody
who would love to have you.
He gave me the address
and I went to see him.
I came to see him, and I
said I don't speak English.
You don't have to speak English.
I will speak English.
We speak for you.
The sketch is what yo make.
That is your ID.
You don't have to speak English.
That was the [inaudible]
foremost designer
with his sister [inaudible].
And then she hired me.
She said I opened up another
place they call [inaudible],
and I want you to go over there to
see what you can do in that place.
I went over there.
They couldn't even make
20 pairs a day, boots.
And I came in and said
everything has to be changed.
You don't work this way.
I say you're not going to punch
a clock and get paid for it.
You've got to work for it piece
by piece and I will teach you,
every one of you, how to make more
money and to help your family.
That's the way I was all
my life helping people.
Believe in people.
That makes life more
rewarding and life for it
because you can still do things
for yourself and for others.
That makes you feel
more excited and good.
To give to somebody a gift,
help, that's the way I live
and I'm going to die by it.
[ Music ]
>> Michlean Amir: Thank you so
much both of you for your responses
and for explaining the
works on your books.
I think that these presentations
only strengthen our understanding
that we can fathom the life of one
person, we can understand one person
when it's six million or even 358,
it's a little bit more difficult to.
One little item about Joe that
Nancy and all that you mentioned
and you didn't say was that
Joe had an identical twin.
And I cannot imagine, this must
have been so difficult for him
to lose his other siblings as
well, but his identical twin.
So we're open now to questions.
If you have any questions for
either of the speakers please.
Yes, sir?
>> I have a question for Nancy.
Nancy, you mentioned
Nazi invasion of Poland.
It was the German invasion of
Poland [inaudible] in German,
German soldiers, German
[inaudible], yes.
I think that to call
names by the right name,
it was a German invasion to Poland.
That's my comment.
>> Michlean Amir: This is a
comment, not really a question.
The comment is that
mentioning the invasion
of Poland it was the
German invasion,
not the Nazi invasion of Poland.
Did you want to comment on it?
>> Nancy Geise: No, thank you.
I think that's an excellent point.
I wanted to say one more thing.
I forgot to mention about Irene.
I said that her father was Polish.
And they lived in Germany
there in the war,
but their time was
also very difficult.
Her only sibling -- about
the time the Nazis knocked
on Joe's door also knocked
on their door in Germany,
accused her only sibling of
being a spy against the Nazis,
took him out and hung him.
>> I've got a question.
>> Michlean Amir: Yes?
>> What do each of you
plan for the future?
I know you're working
on another book.
Nancy, are you going to be
working on another book?
>> Michlean Amir: So the question
is what will the authors be working
on now in the future?
Tony already has a book that
he's working on and, Nancy,
the question is for both of you.
>> Tony Pitch: [Inaudible]
time to sum up.
And I really think the survival of
the Jewish people is phenomenal.
That's the first thing.
So having written this
book I now want
to write something that's a
little bit less distraught
and less suffering in it.
I've writing now, the last two and a
half months I've written 160 pages.
It's easy if you're 12
hours a day like me.
And I'm writing now about a
true love story of World War I.
A woman of 25 years old
was sent from Kansas City
to occupied France by the Red Cross.
And she became director
of entertainment
because the wounded soldiers
and the amputees needed
medication and also laughter.
And at the same time a man
left, he was 26 years old,
left Brooklyn as a lieutenant, and
he was sent to occupied France.
And he was very scared of being
in the combat zone, terrified.
And he was awarded the [inaudible]
by the French for his bravery.
I got letters from both of them
from the Library of Congress.
By sheer chance I looked through
2,000 names before I found theirs.
And then I asked what,
if anything, they had.
It was one box, and there
were 69 letters there.
And then the family in Princeton
and Wisconsin opened up to me,
and the deluged me with documents.
I hope it will come
out before the Library
of Congress has their exhibition
on World War I planned for 2017.
But their experiences are
not only about this war,
the terrible facial wounds
and things like that,
his experiences in warfare.
Twice in one day he
was almost killed.
Once he was in a trench,
and a German soldier jumped
over with a bayonet
and tried to stab him.
They literally had hand-to-hand
combat before he plunged the bayonet
in his enemy.
And then he was in the same
trench when the walls caved in
and he was buried alive almost.
This telegram runner saw this,
went back to headquarters
and said he's dead.
They sent a telegram to
his father in Brooklyn
from a state assemblyman, and
they said your son is dead.
And he walked around for two
hours wondering how he was going
to tell his wife.
And then he went back to the office,
and another cable came
and said he's alive.
He hadn't told his mother.
So his experiences
and her experiences.
Now, that's not the
end of the story.
They came back on the same
ship and they met each other.
There were 4,000 people there,
and they met each other
and they married.
And her fianc was waiting on
shore but he lost out, he lost out.
And they married and they had one
who became a world famous physicist
at Princeton, world
famous, died of leukemia.
And his daughter and his
second wife are the people
who deluged me with information.
>> Michlean Amir: Well, that sounds
like a more upbeat
story of an awful war.
I think that World
War I was overshadowed
by the horrible atrocities
of World War II.
And there's a lot that needs to
be told still about World War I.
So it's excellent that
you're doing that.
Nancy?
>> Nancy Geise: Thank you.
I have another book, but it's
long term off before I even really
start writing.
Because when I write I can't
do much of anything else.
And I really feel like I owe it
to Joe to do everything I can
to get the word about this book
out because I feel like
it is so important.
And so I'm dedicating my time
to speaking about Joe's story.
So if you have any other contacts
let me know around the world.
I would love to speak there.
And I'd love to see it as a
movie someday and a documentary.
So there's a lot of things.
We are in production right
now for an audio book.
And this was so cool.
About three weeks ago I
was in Colorado with Joe.
We took him into this
recording studio.
We were able to record Joe
reading his opening quotes
at the beginning of every chapter.
So I think that will be
really powerful as well.
Because without a driving force
behind somebody behind a book they
don't do much.
>> I was wondering if any of
you have had a personal face-
to-face confrontation with someone
who is a known Holocaust
denier and what happened.
Or if it hadn't happened what
do you think might happen?
>> Michlean Amir: The
question is about any interface
with the Holocaust denier.
I know Nancy has a story about that,
and perhaps Tony has in addition
to what he already said
about the French neo-Nazi.
Nancy?
>> Well, it was interesting.
After we recorded Joe's
voice for the audio book,
I posted it on Facebook what
a neat experience that was.
And some woman, not a Holocaust
denier, but someone posted
on my Facebook, my profession
Facebook page, that, oh, that woman,
meaning me, was just
making this all up.
That Joe is really dead.
That he's been dead a long time.
That there's no such thing
as a 95 year old Holocaust
survivor from Auschwitz.
And so I took that
down from the site.
And I just posted saying that anyone
who denies the Holocaust happens
or denies that Joe
is anything but alive
and well will not permitted
on this site.
Because to do otherwise would be a
disservice and would be very awful
for the memory of all those who
lost their lives including Joe's
whole family.
So I just won't allow that.
But it was kind of
funny because right
after that we were
at a party with Joe.
It was a going away party for
my parents who actually lived
in the same neighborhood.
And so we were able to record
some fun video of saying, now,
does Joe look dead to you?
And he kept saying, no, I'm
alive and I'm well, and he is.
>> Anthony Pitch: I tell you
when this book came out I wrote
to the Southern Poverty Law Center
and also the Simon
Wiesenthal Center.
And I said I want to address Nazis.
And I really was serious about it.
And they both said to me don't.
First of all you won't get an
invitation, and if you do they'll be
after you and your family.
Now, I didn't mind if
they came for me because,
as I said, I had a good life.
But my family I wasn't
prepared for that.
So I dropped that.
But I want to leave
you with one subject.
This is not about horror,
it's about heritage.
And the people who deny the
Holocaust happened they probably
haven't opened a book before.
They don't only live in
the hills of Appalachia
but they're all over the place.
And this really is a
reputation of these people.
The Jews have always survived
bequeathing a triumphant heritage
of endurance.
And the stories in my book testify
to this everlasting resilience.
I phoned a fellow in Switzerland
just before his death last year,
and he said to me,
he was a survivor,
if the Holocaust never
happened where is my family?
And so the deniers are the people
who really are the
scum of the earth.
They were not there.
They haven't researched it.
They haven't talked
to the survivors.
How can they possibly know
what these people endured?
>> Nancy Geise: And I was going
to say one more point to that.
There are people right now
that deny 9/11 ever happened.
A hundred years from now can
you imagine there will be a lot
of people denying that
ever happened.
People like to deny
that evil exists.
Evil does exist.
>> Michlean Amir: Unfortunately.
One more question.
Anyone have another question?
All right, well, the authors
will remain around here
if you'd like to speak with them.
And, again, thank you
very much for coming.
Gail, this was a very
successful program.
Thank you very much for having us.
[Applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.